[Music]
on this Thursday night uncertainty in
the air weather forecasters release
their predictions for this year's
hurricanes and severe storms and we need
to have more action on what we call
climate change adaptation why the severe
weather is proving difficult to predict
demanding answers the opposition calls
the special rap a tour to testify on
foreign interference after David
Johnston ruled out a public inquiry the
insatiable appetite for artificial
intelligence and a new Canadian
investigation into chat GPT plus
Standing Tall I got the accident and had
a spinal cord injury how electronic
brain implants are helping this
paraplegic man to walk again
yeah
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we're getting our first glimpse of
what to expect from this year's
hurricane season and meteorologists warn
it's looking unusually unpredictable the
Pacific hurricane season is already
hitting hard and fast this is the view
from Guam the American Island Southwest
of Los Angeles where typhoon mawar
dropped more than 600 millimeters of
rain the strongest typhoon to hit that
territory in 20 years
well today meteorologists released their
predictions for the Atlantic hurricane
season which officially begins in one
week and as Eric Sorensen reports the
forecast includes a lot of uncertainty
if there were any doubts that hurricanes
could pack a major punch in waters as
far north as Canada Fiona put those to
rest last fall eight months later
memories of the swath cut by Fiona
through turo Nova Scotia are still
chilling for Nicole lenderton it's
terrifying the level and intensity that
we're getting you know hundreds of year
old tree they're not supposed to be
depleted in in a day Fiona demonstrated
that hurricanes can retain high winds in
the North Atlantic fed by increasingly
warm ocean waters the Canadian Hurricane
Center watches a huge area off Canada's
East Coast where every year up to 40
percent of all Atlantic hurricanes come
into their watch Zone not all of these
storms will have an impact on land
however it gives an indication of the
proportion of the in the storms in the
Atlantic that find their way into our
response Zone it's forecast to be a
normal hurricane season but that will
mean 12 to 17 named storms it's expected
five to nine of them will be hurricanes
and between 1 and 4 will be major
hurricanes with Winds of 180 kilometers
an hour or above the U.S National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
says El Nino currents in the Pacific
returning this year should Tamp down
hurricanes but Atlantic Waters warmer
than last year will fuel more storms
that makes this year unpredictable when
we looked at we were like wow this is a
lot of uncertainty this year in the
Outlook well but what is certain some
storms will be fierce these storms are
going to continue to develop faster they
are going to be stronger they will last
longer Noah says new modeling coming
this summer will improve forecasting
further out last year Fiona looked
harmless enough at one point then took
aim at Atlantic Canada before leveling a
direct hit it means Canadians must not
only be more aware of what's coming with
increasing Storm surges
but must do a better job preparing this
is the coastal communities the ones that
are at biggest risk in these things and
we need to have more action on what we
call climate change adaptation building
climate resilient communities Nicole
leonerton doesn't need convincing I hope
that people really recognize the fact
that climate change is real and climate
crisis so what will a normal year look
like with climate change depends on
where you live and where the hurricanes
come ashore in 2023 Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
the Coast Guard is getting some help
from Ottawa in an effort to keep
Canada's waterways safe the federal
government announced plans to spend two
and a half billion dollars on dozens of
new Coast Guard vessels the funds part
of Canada's national shipbuilding
strategy will go towards 61 smaller
boats and barges that can operate in
Shallow Waters Joyce Murray the minister
responsible for the Coast Guard called
the investment critical to help
modernize the fleet with Alberta's
election just days away the energy
industry is in the spotlight with talk
of transformation oil and gas made Fort
McMurray the richest municipality in
Canada for a time but as the industry
looks to reduce emissions another
potential Boom Town is emerging the city
of Cold Lake sits about 300 kilometers
Northeast of Edmonton that's just below
the province's oil sands as Heather
York's West reports it's a prime
location for exponential economic growth
the winters may be long in Cold Lake but
in the summertime this Northern Alberta
Community shines got a beautiful beach
and a lot of people come up here to camp
and to fish over the next several years
people will also be coming to these
streets to fill thousands of new jobs
because this little city is on the brink
of a boom right now people come to Cold
Lake to work at the Air Force Base or in
oil and gas but the community will also
soon be home to one of the largest
carbon capture and storage facilities in
the world luckily the geology in our
area is going to allow the carbon to be
safely stored underground in these big
Caverns it's kind of cool it's the
Cornerstone of the Canadian energy
sector's plan to get to Net Zero by
2050. the country's biggest oil
producers intend to bring their carbon
dioxide emissions 400 kilometers via
pipeline from operations north of Fort
McMurray down to the area south of Cold
Lake
Corey Harvey a local pipeline scheduler
and electrician says the pathways plan
gives him hope that the industry that
has employed him for his entire career
will continue to be around for decades
to come I would say I'm excited about it
it's it's kind of a new path for
Pipelines and Industry entirely now this
is a big project sixteen and a half
billion dollars so we anticipate you
know 25 to 35
000 people required for the construction
phase which will occur over several
years and then several thousand
permanent operations jobs
at the end with the target to begin
capturing and storing carbon by 2030
pathway says it has hundreds of people
working to keep the project on track but
it will still need regulatory approval
and hopes to secure public funds in the
form of tax credits or subsidies before
the carbon can start flowing into the
ground Alberta's is the owner and the
regulator of the resource and clearly
needs to be at the table and uh you know
what post-election I think they'll be
able to engage
till then Cold Lake will just have to
wait and see if the little Beach City
will also become Canada's first clean
technology Boom Town Heather urich's
West Global News Cold Lake Alberta
that potential broom brings some big
challenges tomorrow on global national
Heather looks at the calls for outside
help in the growing Northern community
and global national is hitting the road
next week Donna Friesen will be
broadcasting from Edmonton on Sunday
Monday and Tuesday and tune in for
decision Alberta coverage as voters cast
their ballots in one of the most heated
provincial elections in years
the federal government has announced
more than 12 million dollars for safety
initiatives in aquisition the Indigenous
Community along the St Lawrence River
where eight migrants were found dead
earlier this year
these are monies which will go towards
giving local law enforcement to tools
that you need to keep the community safe
aguasasni is a popular Target for human
Smugglers due to its geography the
Mohawk territory straddles the borders
between Quebec Ontario and New York
state in late March the bodies of eight
migrants from Romania and India were
pulled from the river following what
police call the failed attempt to cross
illegally into the U.S the federal
government says more than 10 million
dollars will go to the aguasasni Mohawk
Police Service to help fight organized
crime and spur cooperation with other
National and international law
enforcement agencies the other funds are
earmarked for local community groups
former governor general and special
rapporteur David Johnston will testify
before a parliamentary committee to
explain why he ruled out holding a
public inquiry into allegations of
foreign election interference in a
55-page report released this week
Johnston concluded that a public inquiry
would effectively be pointless because
much of the classified evidence involved
can't be made public but as Taria Israel
reports A Chorus of Canadians are
rejecting Johnston's decision
special rapporteur and former Governor
General David Johnston hoped his
recommendation would be enough for
opposition MPS it's not all of the
opposition parties have agreed that we
need to hear from Mr Johnston Johnston
is slated to appear before a
parliamentary Committee in less than two
weeks and face questioning after ruling
out a public inquiry on foreign election
interference there was not really any
significant mention of the gaps in
legislation having read uh the right
honorable David Johnston's report which
I think is very measured impartial has
done a thorough analysis to partisan
kind of a bickering
and to me that's a lot of noise Chinese
Canadians have warned the federal
government for years about the threat
and some are disappointed by the
decision simply sweeping everything
under the Rock and saying there will be
no public inquiry I feel that we are
once again abandoned
Johnston calls for an interference a
substantial danger to Canadian democracy
but says a public inquiry would not
provide Canadians with the answers they
seek a public review of classified
intelligence simply cannot be done there
have
public inquiries before where much of
the evidence was top secret like one
looking into the Detention of Canadian
maharar sent by the U.S to a Syrian
prison on faulty information Paul
cavalluzzo was the lead counsel for that
inquiry and believes Johnston missed the
mark this is a situation where people
have lost faith or confidence in how the
government has acted and as a result of
that a way to deal with it in a very
effective way to deal with that as an
independent public inquiry ultimately
the decision on whether to hold a public
inquiry rests with prime minister Justin
Trudeau and he has repeatedly said he
will abide by Johnston's recommendation
Global News Ottawa
the founder of the far-right group Oath
Keepers was sentenced today to 18 years
in prison for his role in plotting and
orchestrating the January 6th Riot on
the U.S Capitol
[Applause]
Stuart Rhodes a former Army paratrooper
and lawyer was found guilty of seditious
conspiracy obstruction of an official
proceeding and tampering with documents
it's the longest sentence handed down to
the thousand plus people charged in
relation to the 2021 attack that saw
Donald Trump's supporters attempt to
block Congress from certifying Joe
Biden's 2020 election victory
it can write essays and drive cars now
artificial intelligence is aiding in the
war against superbugs find out how
coming up
plus with the surging demand for AI
means for stock markets and it's game
over for Canada's most successful
Jeopardy champion
[Music]
scientists in Canada and the U.S have
made a promising new discovery using
artificial intelligence the researchers
from Ontario and Massachusetts used an
AI algorithm to find a potentially
potent antibiotic that could kill a
superbug it needs further testing but
scientists say the antibiotic could have
the power to fight one of the world's
most dangerous antibiotic resistant
bacteria it can cause pneumonia and
meningitis and it's usually found in
hospitals where it can survive on
surfaces for a long period of time the
process could also speed the discovery
of other antibiotics
and the demand for AI is driving chip
giant Nvidia towards a trillion dollar
valuation shares for the company soared
again today since January they've been
on a rapid Ascent surging 85 percent
this year a huge sales Outlook is
fueling demand for the processors which
run AI systems and as microlay reports
Nvidia is closing in on an elite club
that includes Apple Microsoft and
alphabet is there no end to what
artificial intelligence can accomplish
Riz GPT could listen to a conversation
what are your weaknesses my greatest
weakness is that I can get too focused
and feed you a response call it Charisma
on demand the engine fueling the AI boom
was only unveiled in November yet every
major company is integrating chat GPT
and its platforms chat GPT is the most
sort of fast growing consumer app we've
ever seen
Nvidia known for decades to Gamers for
their videographic ships also makes the
microchips AI is run on and saw its
stocks soar Thursday pushing it onto the
list of top 10 most valuable companies
in the world this is one of the most
historical guidance raises of any large
cap tech company in the last 30 years
it's a jaw dropper historical as Nvidia
is really seen as AI Gold Rush play out
in real time it's a historical earnings
for NVIDIA as well as the tech space as
the leading AI chip manufacturer
analysts predict nvidia's valuation to
grow more way more with projections that
they could overtake Amazon as the fourth
most valuable company in the world but
not everyone is happy with the rate with
which AI is growing earlier this month
The toronto-based Godfather of AI
Jeffrey Hinton issued a warning
suggesting AI outperforming humans posed
an imminent existential threat and
privacy authorities Inc Canada are now
investigating open AI which makes chat
GPT for disclosing the personal
information of users I am a Visionary
while Nvidia is cashing in some see the
risk for investors increasing as the
market gets crowded with more AI options
Tech technology entrepreneurs and
investors that are really sort of trying
to chase these companies uh too fast
right they're not necessarily doing
their due diligence on them they're not
necessarily vetting the core team and so
I do think that there is a lot of hype
and a lot of you know potential for
failure
and there's no AI solution for that yet
microlay Global News Toronto
[Music]
buyer's remorse still ahead why some
young Canadians are regretting their
real estate Investments
Canadian Millennials who invested in the
real estate market when interest rates
were low are starting to reconsider
their purchases as inflation Rises along
with interest rates some landlords are
now thinking about offloading their
investment properties altogether and
gaviola explains
young landlords have benefited from Red
Hot rental markets across the country
and until the last year low costs on
mortgages but now many are struggling to
cover higher borrowing costs and are
rethinking their investment people get
into the sector
decide they don't like being landlord
and they get out or they overestimate
the return they're going to make on the
property or underestimate the expenses
more than one in ten are about 4.4
million currently own an investment
property according to an online poll a
third owned two or more properties and
multiple property owners are more likely
to be aged 34 and under than older than
35. the stock market has been a tough
place a lot of negative returns and so
people are looking at the real estate
market and saying you know that might be
a better place for my investment but
more than 30 percent of investment
property owners are considering selling
because of higher lending rates
especially in Toronto Vancouver and
Montreal new data from the Canada
mortgage and housing Corporation shows
Residential Mortgage Debt hit a record
2.08 trillion in January that is up six
percent in a year and there's news this
week the Canadian household debt has
eclipsed GDP and and is the highest
among G7 countries along with this an
uptick in mortgages in arrears that does
remain a potential vulnerability for our
financial system in our report we're
already seeing some early signs that's
from the mortgage consumers may be under
Financial strain for those looking to
unload an investment property need to
consider the business case understand
all costs and fees for changing course
they're gonna have to pay capital gains
on any appreciation they've earned for
the last few years or from the time they
started renting it out as an investment
property that will also impact their
bottom line a wave of investors getting
out of the housing market at once can
amplify Trends stoking a hot housing
market and potentially creating a
steeper price plunge as activity cools
and gaviola Global News Toronto
digital brain Bridge next the technology
helping a man overcome his paralysis
[Music]
when we add the 24 800 they earned in
the first half
it's not quite enough that brings them
to 41 685.
Canadian quiz whiz Mateo roach couldn't
quite clinch the Jeopardy Masters title
but still managed to cash in big earning
250 000 US Dollars that's a little over
340 000 Canadian sadly roach's father
died during the taping of that
tournament roach said he instilled a
love of learning and was a big part of
why they competed on the show roach is
the most successful Canadian competitor
in Jeopardy history
a 40 year old Dutch quadriplegic who was
told he would never walk again is doing
just that walking standing even climbing
stairs thanks to a new medical device
the technology combines implants with a
wearable Hardware system now so far he's
the only person to try the device but
his Crystal commencing Reports with his
positive results his medical team is
hoping more people can regain some
control and Mobility
hertan ozcam has an incomplete spinal
cord injury yet he's walking under his
own power aided by a mostly internal
medical device
this communication is interrupted
our idea was to re-establish this
communication with a digital Bridge
neurosurgeons implanted two disc shaped
electrodes in his brain a second surgery
was then performed where he was fitted
with an electrode on his spinal cord at
the location responsible for leg
movements when he thinks about walking
the electrodes in his head pick up that
signal sending it to an external device
in a backpack that he wears that
Hardware decodes the information
skipping over the injured spinal cord
and sends it to the implanted signal
pulse generator triggering his leg
muscles the patient has first to learn
how to work with his brain signals and
we also have to learn how to correlate
this brain signal to the spinal cord
stimulation but this is pretty short
over the course of 40 training sessions
oxam was able to stand walk even climb
some stairs Within 5-10 minutes I could
control my
hips like they were like
the brain implant picked up what I was
doing with my hips so that was like
yeah the best outcome I think for
everyone the medical team's findings
have been published in the journal
Nature and they see huge potential for
the device not only he could leverage
the digital bridge in order to control
its paralyze muscle but also show a
recovery of neurological function yet
lost for many years
suggesting that this digital Bridge also
promote the growth of new nerve
connections while there is reason for
optimism more trials are needed to see
if the results can be replicated in
other people and if the digital Bridge
can work for people with injuries to
other areas of the spinal cord Crystal
gomancing Global News London
and that is global national for this
Thursday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is white shell Provincial
Park that's about 120 kilometers east of
Winnipeg we love seeing your Canada so
please email your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Farah Nasser will be at the anchor desk
with you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]